ibm cloud databases enabled by ibm cloud
satellite
tls certificates management and the ibm
prevail conference
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to get the ball rolling this week i want
to talk a bit about distributed cloud
and databases as a service or dbas
recently we've seen the introduction of
distributed cloud databases
unlocks the value of dbas and makes the
capabilities consistently available
globally
that's why we're excited to announce
that ibm cloud databases
are now enabled by ibm cloud satellite
for distributed cloud workloads
this is going to enable the deployment
of production grade databases
in your data centers into your account
on other cloud service providers or in
edge locations
this will also allow you to scale
databases across any environment with
improved security
and a consistent set of management
capabilities for popular
open source data services you'll even be
able to bring databases to where the
application lives
resulting in reduced latency and
networking charges
to learn more about the benefits of
using ibm cloud databases enabled by ibm
cloud satellite
check out the link i've got in the
description of this video
next up i want to take a look at how you
can now store retrieve and manage tls
certificates
and other cloud secrets in ibm cloud
secrets manager
by using secrets manager as a central
repository for your tls certificates
you'll get data isolation and built-in
encryption options for protecting
secrets at rest
this provides the end-to-end data
security you need to host certificates
of any sensitivity other benefits of
using secrets manager as a central
repository include the ability to
centralize your secrets at scale define
access with secret groups
protect your secrets at rest and monitor
and audit activity
to learn more about managing your tls
certificates with secrets manager
check out the link below to close out
things this week
i'm going to tell you a bit about the
upcoming ibm prevail conference in
october
sponsored by the ibm academy of
technology prevail is a technical
conference hosted by technical people
for a technical audience it's a virtual
event from october 19th to 21st that is
devoted to the themes of i.t
resilience performance security quality
testing
and site reliability engineering we've
got some great keynote speakers lined up
but we'd also like to invite you to
submit papers for this year's event
some examples of topics that would fit
into the themes i mentioned are
agile methods devops pipelines internet
of things
microservices or chaos engineering to
register for the ibm prevail conference
or submit a paper check out the link
below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description in this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now
you